hoje eu vim aqui pra dividir com vocês
uma experiência de vida que me mudou
radicalmente e e acredito que possa
mudar algum de vocês pelo menos talvez
seja o motivo de deus teve tudo aquilo
em 2004 eu resolvi passar férias na
tailândia um paraíso é todos conhecem um
lugar realmente maravilhoso é é uma era
passar umas férias de 10 dias à ilha se
chama o que e quando eu cheguei eu fui
com a minha ex namorada quando eu
cheguei até a ilha foi recepcionado pela
dona do hotel que nos levou até a
pousada quando nós chegamos lá na
pousada ela me disse que o quarto que eu
tinha reservado pra pra ficar aqui nos
dez dias
esse quarto estava estava ocupado e que
a gente teria que ficar no quarto andar
que não era um lugar que eu tinha
programado
não entendi na hora porque ameaça
entende não concordei e fui para o
quarto que que fiquei no quarto andar
no primeiro dia passamos o dia na praia
tirado na praia é no segundo dia
nós alugamos um carro e passeamos pela
id conhecendo conhecendo a ilha do sul
da hino lugar realmente de mar
transparente de areias brancas e nem
onda tem é no terceiro dia
nós resolvemos alugar uma moto porque a
gente tinha gostado da da segunda praia
da praia mais perto da nossa e achamos
que poderia ser perto poderia ser mais
fácil de moto do que a gente cá passamos
o dia na praia tomando sol caminhada
enfim o dia no de diversão com qualquer
um de vocês já passou atrás
na volta quando nós voltamos pra praia
de nosso hotel
eu resolvi que eu queria mergulhar no
dia seguinte à minha namorada não queria
ela estava queimada do sol e achou que
que não queria passar o dia ali
além disso a gente tinha uma promoção
para poder ficar
aquela moto mais um dia e conhecer a
ilha e mesmo assim eu bati o pé e
resolvi que queria mergulhar a contra
gosto dela que foi tomar banho na
pousada
eu peguei a moto de ouvir para
provocação da moto e comprar o pacote
para mergulhar no dia seguinte a gente
sairia do hotel às oito da manhã e
passaria o dia mergulhando em duas ilhas
pé e voltaria no final do dia mas quando
eu cheguei no hotel e de noite saiu
muita gente iria mergulhar brigou comigo
que não queria ir que não era esse o
combinado e foi a contragosto às 8 da
manhã do dia seguinte era o combinado
eles buscaram a gente na pousada pra
poder ir pro pir de ter um treinamento
de mergulho e depois desse treinamento a
gente pegar em um barco pra pra fazer o
passeio quando foi 8 da manhã eu sentei
na porta da pousada para esperar eles
porque no horário combinado não se
entendem e as oito da manhã eu sentir um
tremor de terra mas eu nunca tinha
vivido aquilo não foi nada muito forte
foi a mesma sensação de ter um caminhão
pesado passando pela rua e eu sentia
aquele tremor
não entendi o que estava acontecendo
poucos minutos depois ela veio de seus
carros veio também foi você sentiu o
terremoto não será que foi um terremoto
a gente está na ilha pode ter passado um
caminhão pesado na outra rua
pode ser qualquer outra coisa e não
demos importância aquele fato buscaram a
gente conforme combinado cinco dez
minutos depois levar a gente copia a
gente teve um treinamento de mergulho e
quando foi nove e meia da manhã hora
local da verdade porque da tailândia de
onde a gente estava a gente entrou num
barco mais aproximadamente talvez 15
pessoas de diferentes nacionalidades e
fomos em direção a ele para mergulhar
num lugar paradisíaco um sol escaldante
é no cenário maravilhoso
quando chegamos na primeira ilha oahu a
pessoa que estava cuidando daquele
passeio que estava pilotando um barco
disse pra gente olha o mar muito mexido
e vocês não vão poder mergulhar marta
turnos e não vão poder mergulhar aqui
então nós vamos para a segunda ilha a
minha ex namorada naquele momento me
disse te falei meu sexto sentido está
falando pra gente não vi eu te disse que
a gente deveria ter vindo se a gente
tivesse ficado mal passei tinha sido
mais interessante deveria ter vindo e
assim alguns minutos
todo mundo já teve ou tem uma relação
sabe como funciona essa conversa
depois desse tempo é a gente estava em
direção à segunda ele para mergulhar e
no caminho da segunda ilha o piloto do
barco marinha no bairro para roubar e
pediu que a gente vestindo coletes salva
vidas dizendo que a capitania dos portos
da marinha estava vindo fazer uma
fiscalização
nós vestimos aqueles coletados e essa
fiscalização não aconteceu
hoje eu consigo perceber e entender que
até o tempo todo estava no rádio
conversando com alguém o tempo todo no
rádio naquele momento a gente não tinha
percebido isso não tinha entendido
porque o que houve foi que essa
fiscalização não vêem a gente ficou
parada em alto mar por alguns minutos e
ele disse pra gente que tinha acontecido
um problema e que a gente deveria voltar
para a ilha de onde a gente tinha saído
que era porque aí a minha namorada me
disse te falei para não virem perdemos o
dia
gastamos dinheiro e não valeu apenas ali
me disse e eu a defender como os homens
os maridos ou namorados fazem
normalmente
levantei disso o programa já dodô passei
pois perdi o dia não estão voltando pro
nosso pai nosso para a nossa ilha e no
mergulhamos não conhecemos nada eles
simplesmente olhou pra mim disse
amanhã você resolve isso vai ter tempo
manhã para resolver não entendi bem
voltamos ao píer
quando chegamos no ppi já tinha uma cena
caótica barcos revirados moto o
estacionamento onde tinha motos e carros
estavam revirados
é a estrutura do píer já não existia
mais
e eu como como leigo não conhecia a
palavra tsunami onda gigante não entendi
o que estava acontecendo naquele momento
a única coisa que disseram para a gente
era pra correr barulho de ambulância
todo o tempo um caos imagine um atentado
terrorista naquele momento e corremos
por uma quadra ou duas quadras o grupo
tava junto àquelas pessoas do bairro
quando chegamos na esquina o guia vai
até a gente disse o que houve foi uma
onda gigante
e a gente está esperando por outras
ondas gigantes o prudente para a saúde
de vocês é a gente até o topo de uma
montanha pra salvar a vida de vocês
mesmo e assim nós fizemos naquele
momento encostou um carro uma
caminhonete nós entramos na carroceria
atrás da caminhonete e subimos até a
montanha lá no topo dessa montanha já
estavam estavam muitas pessoas muitas
pessoas
os locais e turistas tinha muita gente
naquele lugar é e dali a gente começa a
ter noção do que estava acontecendo
porque tinha um rapaz que estava com com
o som do carro ligado
o dono do restaurante que falava inglês
bem e estava traduzindo pra mim o que
estava acontecendo e nós tivemos noção
um pouco do que estava acontecendo
quando o país tem sido atingido quando
as pessoas até aquele momento tinha sido
dado com dados como mortas e e assim e
assim a gente passou algum tempo
daí a pouco nos disseram o que causou
essa onda que chegou na ilha que estava
às 9 55 da manhã
foi um terremoto de escala 9 pontos na
escala richter que aconteceu em sumatra
às 8 da manhã foi exatamente o terremoto
que eu sentia oito da manhã
mas como ainda estava longe do epicentro
do terremoto é só demorou para chegar
até aproximadamente uma hora e 55
eles disseram para a gente no topo da
montanha que tinha acontecido outro
terremoto de mais intensidade na escala
richter e que essa onda que viria a
maior do que a primeira tinha vindo
e que ela ia chegar a aproximadamente
uma hora da tarde
isso era meio dia a gente estava sentado
no meio do mato olhando para o mar
esperando ver uma onda que a gente não
sabia o tamanho nem se depois dessa onda
a gente está ali e assim nós passamos
uma hora olhando para o mar esperando o
que ia acontecer ainda não veio
e assim nós passamos o dia sentado nesse
lugar tentando entender o que aconteceu
às 6 da tarde disseram pra gente que a
gente não poderia ficar animais que não
tinha iluminação e nos convidaram pra ir
pro centro da ilha onde tinha uma
estrutura pra gente ali é chegamos lá
cadastrar o nome da gente e levaram a
gente para um abrigo porque atrai que a
gente estava aqui era patton limite era
a praia mais atingida ea prefeitura está
retirando os corpos ali é dali fomos
para o primeiro abrigo estava cheio
fomos para o segundo obriga o que achei
fomos pro terceiro abrigo e ali a gente
ficou naquele abrigo a gente viu de tudo
pessoas vindo do hospital com
contraturas abertas porque não tinha
tido tratamento histórias horripilantes
eu eu lembro bem e fico arrepiado na
história de d nesse momento um rapaz
sueco sentou do meu lado e me disse é eu
tentei segurar com toda a minha força
não conseguir segurar o que eu estava na
praia com minha esposa e minha filha de
3 anos e uma onda veio e eu tentei
segurá los com toda a minha força e não
conseguiu e assim histórias uma atrás da
outra uma história pra outra
passamos a noite de olhos arregalados no
domingo e nem um minuto
na manhã seguinte conseguimos contato
com a embaixada do brasil que nos disse
para ir à prefeitura fomos até a
prefeitura devia ter aproximadamente 5
mil pessoas na prefeitura tinha uma
organização tinha comida tinha água
tinha telefone tinha internet e nós
ficamos ali naquela prefeitura tentando
ver o que a gente ia fazer porque com a
gente tinha uma camiseta 15 dólares
e um pacote de biscoito de passar o dia
a gente repassa o dinheiro é naquele
momento tentamos contato com a embaixada
no brasil que teria uma estrutura nível
de embaixador não tinha chegado
e assim nós ficamos aguardando para ver
como me como iríamos resolver
naquele lugar tinha um alto falante onde
ele estava anunciando alguns transportes
para as praias e sempre anunciando
algumas praias a praia que a gente
estava nunca era anunciada patton limite
e eu fui até o local para perguntar por
que não têm transporte para o ambiente
olha o papão beach foi o lugar mais
atingido da ilha eles tinham
aproximadamente 400 mortos na praia mas
se você tiver preparado pra ver o pior
eu posso te levar até lá eu pensei
comigo pior pior estou vivendo aqui e
não tem documento não tem dinheiro todo
mês de uma tragédia precisa sair daqui
instinto de sobrevivência e ele nos
levou até lá viu de tudo
corpos destruição prédios no chão
[Música]
no primeiro dia como eu comecei a
história eles me disseram que o meu
quarto não estava disponível que era no
térreo e que por isso estava no quarto
andar
o dia d e para o meu quarto era aquele
dia então eu ainda estava no quarto
andar do hotel estava com a porta
fechada
faltava estrutura torta muito entulho em
volta e consegui quebrar uma janela
passei pra dentro do hotel estava muito
escuro então eu lembro de tatear de
passar o pé nas coisas para não bater em
nada tinha corpos dentro do hotel e eu
consegui subir até o quarto andar e nem
as coisas não todas mas aporte de
dinheiro tudo que precisava para a saída
daquele pesadelo
peguei as nossas coisas foram até o
hotel e daí conseguimos entrar no avião
e 48 horas depois sair desse pesadelo
eu queria passar um vídeo pra vocês pra
mostrar um pouco do que aconteceu
naquele dia
[Música]
ae
naquele dia
aproximadamente 300 mil pessoas morreram
das quais 70 mil 70 mil pessoas nunca
foram nem organizados e aí eu 25 minutos
antes dessa onda que fez tudo isso saí e
voltei 25 minutos depois
depois disso não tem nenhum dia que eu
não acorde com a pergunta por que eu não
porque eu não
e aí você entre 11 milhões de
espermatozóides foi escolhido batalhe
porque nós tivemos esse privilégio
eu de renascer naquele momento e você é
escolhido para viver
você vai passar a vida esperando alguma
coisa se vai passar a vida esperando uma
motivação para tomar uma atitude
você vai passar a vida esperando para
trocar de emprego o emprego que fazem
feliz
não faz sentido só esperando que espera
uma onda vinha acabar com tudo 300 mil
pessoas você tem chance todo dia pode
recomeçar todo dia você vai estudar
medicina e engenharia por que seu pai
quer e vai deixar o seu sonho de lado
não faz sentido a vida é uma só o
recomeço é todo dia você vai esperar o
que
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]